All right, so we aren't quite enough.
If you would please go ahead and introduce yourself by the name of the State Television.
Okay, I'm Bill Robbins, formerly, William G. Robbins.
Today is March 27, 2012, and we're in the third floor of the Oregon State University Library.
And this is an interview having to do with my long-time esteemed colleague, William
Appleman Williams.
So that is what we are in, principally, interested in time by today.
If you could give us a little context, though, just kind of a brief, something else, but
to be your own life in your career.
Okay, I'm Connecticut Yankee by birth, and have some residents with Bill Williams career.
I spent four years in the Navy.
I did not, however, attend the Naval Academy.
I was a listed man right out of high school.
I went to undergraduate school after the Navy experience.
I was out actually five years out of high school before I went to school, got a degree in a
small teachers college in Connecticut, spent one semester at Syracuse University, and then
moved to Oregon in 1963, taught school for one year, and began taking graduate seminars
at the University of Oregon, and finished a master's degree in British history at the
University of Oregon in 1965, moved east to the University of Maine where I had ambitions
to do a PhD.
It didn't work out there for reasons that are not pertinent to this discussion.
When I returned to Oregon in the fall of 1966 in American history, and received the
PhD in 1969, and began teaching here and there on visiting appointments and wound up at Oregon
State in 1971, and I was here for three or four years on visiting appointments, and one
of them I know was when Bill Williams took a research leave, and with the proviso that
I be some of the money used to be higher to hire me as another interim appointment for
that year, and then I got on a tenure track, and so I was at Oregon State from 1971 full
time till 1999, and I went half-time and retired full time in 2002.
So Williams came to us in 1968?
1968.
For good.
It sounds like there was an interaction with him before then.
Well, briefly, and it's a fun story, and I'm glad you asked that question.
I was a graduate student.
I first discovered Bill Williams when I was at the University of Maine.
And it had directly to do with the anti-war movement having to do with Vietnam, and sometime
in the fall of 1965, or spring of 1966, I started reading Williams.
I read Tragedy of American Diplomacy first, and then I read articles that he wrote on various
publications, Minority of One, and the Progressive, having to do with American Foreign Relations
and so forth.
And so when I came back to return to the University of Oregon to work on the PhD, I was fully
vested in my research project, but I was also fully vested in anti-war activities on campus
and in Eugene Community.
And by the fall of 1968 when Bill moved from Madison to Corvallis, I was writing my doctoral
dissertation at that point, and stunned to hear that he had moved to Oregon State.
I mean, speechless.
And it had to do with a perception, mostly erroneous, that we had his graduate students at University
of Oregon, that the Oregon State University was a bastion of reactionary politics and so
forth.
That I learned, of course, was a far stretch when I came here and joined the faculty.
But to make this story, to bring it current, in late January of 1969, the University of
Oregon history faculty invited Bill to campus.
And it was his first appearance back on campus since he left.
He had been there before, but giving a formal address on campus.
And I think it was January 29, 1969 or January 28, 1969.
And it was the onset of a huge snowstorm, that you can go into newspapers, you can find
it, confirm it.
But it was on a Friday night, and he spoke to a packed hall in Urb Memorial Room 105.
And I was there as were all of my graduate student colleagues, who were a pretty eclectic
and very bright bunch.
Maybe the best group of graduate students at the U of O ever had in history, my guess.
Anyway, I can't remember Bill's, just what the substance of his address was.
But the next day, Mitz mounting snowfall, he spoke to graduate students in Chapman Hall,
which was a place where graduate students would gather.
And I can't remember what ticker college or department Chapman Hall was associated with.
And it was kind of a Q and A. And, of course, I was enamored with Bill and I was all fired
up with a major question I wanted to know what drove him to become the person he did, something
like that.
And I'm sure I articulated my question like an idiot.
I will never forget his response.
This is a direct quote.
What the hell kind of a question is that?
Totally humiliated.
And after I got to know Bill, I would tell him that story and he said, oh, I wouldn't have said something.
I said, you sure did.
So, well, in other words, Bill was a historian's historian.
If you read the essays that Paul's working on the unpublished essays,
they're reek with history, with a sense of history.
And my question had nothing to do with that, had to do with political activism,
presentess politics, and so forth.
Just the opposite of the kind of person that Bill was.
Did you ever going to answer your question?
No.
I can't remember it.
It went on from there.
I think I started looking furtively out the window at the mounting snow.
I don't know how Bill ever got home.
He was living in Newport at the time.
Because Eugene came to a standstill.
I remember 43 inches of snowfall in little over 24 hours.
But it sounds like tragedy was an important part of UX and contours as well.
Contours much greater than tragedy.
I used to say on my desk, I had Webster's Dictionary in contours of American history.
And it influenced in a large way, because I consulted it regularly
in teaching the United States history.
And I can't remember the details, but I can say that when I was teaching Pacific Northwest history
about the Lewis and Clark expedition, I consult the index and find Lewis and Clark
and Jefferson and so forth.
And I remember a line that I would quote to students
from contours of American history.
That Jefferson was the great American Democrat.
Jefferson was the great American Empire Builder.
Right in the same Vogue.
Contours and Paul Beall-Barris Saisout was a major, major book that historians have still have to contend with.
So your experience was not isolated by any question?
No, no. I don't think so.
But beyond that, when I came here and joined the faculty in 1971
in my constant association with Bill,
I began to think much more seriously and it really did direct my research in publication for many years
is his notion of political economy, the intersection between politics and economics.
And here I became interested in natural resource industries
and the intersection of politics and economics and something that has stayed with me ever since.
What sounds like you came to LSU about three years after wings,
but that you know much about the courtship or the hiring of boys.
I do and mainly from Bill.
And I should have brought my doctoral dissertation with me because I have to say
that in the fall of 1969, I taught a US history course here on Tuesdays and Thursdays.
And it was Tuesdays and Thursdays when Bill was here because that was his schedule.
And he read my dissertation and he wrote in his beautiful script just some comments.
And I'll try to remember to scan them and send you copies because they're interesting.
He took young scholars seriously.
And what was your question now?
Oh, yes.
Well, the whole background to that is failing marriage to Karen.
And I'm not sure if Paul Buil was altogether right about Bill's...
Paul would argue that Bill's theme was that a woman's place was in the home.
And I'm not so sure about that.
And I'm not sure my wife would agree with that either.
But that's Paul's view.
And there's enough evidence to say that's true.
And Karen's restlessness of wanting to go on and get a degree as it turns out at Portland State
because they had a social work program.
I'm losing my train of thought, a response to your question.
Right.
We made friends with George Carson here.
And I think that's clear from recorded literature.
And they liked each other.
That was important.
And George was very bright and he was no one's fool.
And he liked Bill.
And then there were negotiations about the possibility of hiring Williams.
And the president at the time I think was Jensen.
Yeah.
And Paul Buil has it that a dean was involved because there were questions raised about Bill's trustworthiness
because he was a radical and so forth.
And I remember Bill saying it was Jensen.
And that president Jensen put in a call to Fred Harvey Harrington.
And I don't know whether Harrington yet had become president of University of Wisconsin or not.
But asked him, and I remember Bill saying it was Jensen who called Harrington
and asked him if Williams was trustworthy.
And Bill said, Harrington said, he is.
And Bill, I remember him saying, I get the job.
And that's about all I can add.
I know that there's correspondence, George Carson.
And I think Tom McClinick, Tom was sitting in, I know, for George.
Part of the time when George was on leave.
So I don't know.
But all that correspondence is here.
Did you have any sense of what a success went up?
Did you have the part of what you defined to be right?
Well, I hadn't changed much when I came here in 1971.
And, you know, there was a dearth of people publishing.
And that's been very kindly.
But that wasn't unusual in most land-bent universities in other places either.
One of the more active people publishing at the time in colonial history was Darryl Wax.
And he would, when Tom McClinick stepped down from being chair of the department,
Darryl became chair of the department.
Late 70s, something like this.
And so Darryl was chair through the rest of Bill's tenure on the faculty.
But other than that, you know, I, one well-known member of the faculty,
was promoted to full professor on the basis of three articles published.
And I was going up for a full professor the same year in the dean at the time,
who died a long time ago, tried to get me to draw my bid for promotion to full professor
because I hadn't been associate professor for very long either.
And, but I was publishing articles and I had a book in press.
And I remember it was just before the Christmas break and he asked me,
suggested that I would draw my candidacy.
And I was a little bit offended, but I was talking to the dean and I said that,
you know, I thought that I had the credentials.
My resume was strong enough for promotion.
And I had in mind this other person was going up for promotion.
And I assured him that I wasn't going to jump off to all buildings or anything if I was denied.
And anyway, it was turned down.
And I learned subsequently that the vote among the senior review team here was close.
So...
No, but I remember talking to the person who actually had become good friends with since.
Who told me and he got promoted was that you just have to wait your turn.
Which didn't cheer my Irish sensibilities very much.
But those were interesting times.
And I was feisty, cocky in some ways, but I was publishing a lot.
And my first book was published in 1982.
Bill read the introductory chapter.
I'll never forget it before I sent it off for publication.
Do you want to hear that story?
I wrote it and rewrote it and revised it.
And until I was sure that it was near perfect.
And my wife, my family and I were living out on the Elsi highway at the time.
And we drove down our long driveway and for some reason she was driving.
And I reached in our mailbox and pulled out.
There it was with Williams's handwriting.
And I opened it up as we were driving into town and pulled out.
The manuscript and I told this to graduate students.
Red pen.
It looked like he had cut himself and bled.
Am I perfect writing?
But oh did I learn about writing?
Not just redundancies, but repetitive word use.
The use of that in which, the proper use of that in which,
the proper use of these in those.
And those are only, I should have saved that.
I don't think I have that anymore.
But it was a priceless piece of editorial work.
So it sounds like it became how I used to call these friends pretty quickly.
We did.
It's been a while to, as I used to say, when I first came here speaking to Bill,
I always felt like I had a hot potato in my mouth.
But I got over that.
And I would say by 1973, 1974, you know, I was sort of beyond that.
And it became friends, and eventually very good friends.
I was divorced in 1972.
So Bill never met my first wife.
And I was single for three years.
Bill and Wendy were married in fall of 1972, December of 1972.
They went to British Columbia, I think, to Vancouver.
And I didn't remarry until the summer of 1975.
And this is what Paul Bill misses in his biography of Bill Williams is his sense of play.
A profound sense of play.
Even the memos he would write to the History Department, which are fun reading.
Part of it is his sense of play.
Sometimes it's very cryptic, but a beautiful sense of play.
Bill and Wendy came to our wedding.
And when we walked out of the church, at the end of the ceremony,
tied to ornamentation on the outside of the church.
We're balloons brought by Bill.
Well, my next question sort of fits along in this band.
I'm interested to know a bit more about his personal.
Yeah. Well, Paul mentions this in his biography.
But I don't think he struck how important it was to Bill.
As on Tuesdays and Thursdays, we would go down to the Krivales Hotel,
and the Krivales Hotel in the bottom floor that since long been gone,
were two great pool tables.
And you could buy beer or beverages there.
And we would shoot pool.
And Bill was the best pool player.
And there would be Ben Murgeck from our department,
who was kind of a crotchety cranky guy,
really a base of wonderful human being, but sometimes difficult to get along with.
I mean, even for his best friends, one was Bill,
and I was a good friend of Ben's, too.
Ben was a good pool player.
Peter Kopeck, who was the founding director of the Center for Humanities,
was a regular there.
And there would be various others who would join for at different times.
But those were always wonderful get-togethers,
and then Bill would catch the Greyhound back to Newport.
That was part of it.
Bill, what was the conversation like?
Oh, it varied from politics to history to sports.
And I know there was a television set,
and it could have been after the Krivales Hotel closed,
and we moved on to somewhere else.
And I think it was, and I can't remember where we played pool after that.
But it was during the baseball playoffs,
and when Nolan Ryan pitched for that Houston Astros,
and Bill was a preeminent sports fan,
and especially baseball.
And he was enamored with watching Nolan Ryan pitch.
Well, he was a pain in the neck when, you know, it was his turn to shoot,
and he's up watching television set watching Nolan Ryan pitch.
But Paul Beall misses that part of Bill's life,
and that was a very rich part of his life, too.
And you probably, I'm sure this is in my brief biography
of a sketch of Bill in the Fesheriff, a wonderful line,
and I think it was from Lloyd Gardner,
and not Walter LaFabre, that in his seminars,
Bill would chide them during fall semester,
when the Yankees were always playing in the playoffs,
well, there was no playoffs then.
He simply won the American League Championship,
and went to the World Series,
and all of his graduate students would be anti.
They'd be Yankee haters, and Bill would chide them that they just,
they didn't understand power.
To understand power, you have to understand the Yankees.
It was neat to see how he could take sports metaphor
and switch it into a discussion of, you know,
his kind of history, his approach to history.
Did you take an interest in the local teams?
Oh, yes.
He was a very close fan of Ralph Miller's great basketball teams
in the late 70s and early 80s, really.
And he actually probably met Ralph on different occasions.
I can't remember the details, but he knew and liked him.
And he had Ralph's daughter Shannon in his class,
at some point.
And Shannon also was a student in one of my classes as well.
And she was on the woman's basketball team here,
and very good.
Yes, right.
How would it seem to you then?
Well, I've given you a flare for that already,
I think his play with words, especially in memos to the history department,
which I think I saved most of them.
And you, over between my collection and whatever you gathered elsewhere,
they're great reading.
And they're also steeped in historical metaphors.
And what I always enjoyed about those is the sense of play.
That, you know, this was part fun, part humor, and so forth,
and that you never could take yourself all that seriously.
And I should have better responses to,
but that was part of Bill's persona, I think,
that you never take yourself all that seriously.
And I think that that's part of his differences
with Arthur Meyer, Slesinger, Jr.
was that Slesinger certainly took himself very seriously.
And I assume that this personality there is before itself about conversation.
Oh, yes.
I have to say one other thing.
I told this to Paul Bill when he interviewed me,
when he was working on the biography, that Bill was,
I told him Bill was the best idea person I'd ever met.
And Paul came close to agreeing, but he had one other person in mind,
the best idea person he ever met.
And that's CLR James, the Caribbean Marxist Revolutionary,
and one of the greatest cricketers of all time.
You might check Paul's biography of CLR James.
Where do you think this came from?
Especially as exactly the brightness of this kind of thing?
Well, you know, to use the old metaphor,
thinking outside the box, no one thought outside the box like Williams.
And Paul does a good job of that.
That he looked at that looked at historical questions
from the side or kind of an opaque view.
And he saw raised questions that no one ever raised before.
Or thought about things in a unique and different way.
And that's what I think his work is so transformative in American foreign relations.
Because, you know, old-style diplomatic history never looked at it
from the approach that Bill did, you know, in his book,
The Roots of the Modern American Empire is kind of a classic study
looking at agriculture and agriculture, American agriculture,
and its search for markets and the force that that had in the late 19th century
and shaping American foreign relations certainly is a powerful way of looking at that.
Did you ever talk about the influences upon him and kind of developing the role of the beardless thing?
Yeah. Oh, beard.
In fact, the beard would be a common point of discussion over the pool table.
And every once in a while, Lloyd Gardner or Walt Faeber,
somebody like that would come up with something out of the beard papers,
although beard burned all his papers, I think.
But it was a reference to beard that they found in somebody else's correspondence
and so forth, and he would share that with me,
and probably some of it maybe in what I've turned over
to the archives here, the collection.
So, yeah, beard was a constant point of reference.
And I, you know, of course, well aware of beard,
and especially his point about the influence on the shaping of America's early period of history
and especially the making the constitutional convention that the constitutional makers
were not some of our current politicians.
Today descended from on high, but rather they had their hand in the cookie jar,
so that was part of my understanding, too, of political economy.
Did you ever visit the first bread, that's a good point?
No. No. I don't even know where it was.
No. In fact, by the time Carla and I visited their wallpour,
and I think the two of us were there together,
I never visited Bill there alone, then he and Wendy were married by the time
I was making trips to the coast to visit them.
What Bill did was he bought two cabins,
and then when he and Wendy were married, they built a partition,
which housed a kitchen, a small dining room, and so forth.
And then one end became a study in their bedroom
and the other end was a living room.
And then eventually after we knew them several years,
they built a bigger bedroom and a garage over the other end.
But it was very livable and very appropriate for them,
and it backed up right on a bluff over the ocean, as you probably know.
We talked earlier before to write a study.
I wanted to be able to reiterate your recollections about that.
This was not recorded though, that was over coffee.
Lostier, Spartan, beautiful desk, bookcase,
hardbound books, not many of them.
The study was not filled with wall-to-wall books.
It's the neatest study I've ever seen.
It's probably an expression of Bill's work.
You talked about this a little bit already.
How did the logistics work out of living on that building?
Well, he had an agreement when he signed his contract
that he wouldn't have to be here every day,
because he wanted to live on the coast.
And, you know, wanted to teach a Tuesday, Thursday schedule.
And I know there was some resentment over that.
I was privy to it.
And I thought it was nonsense, because it came from people
who were doing nothing and had zero prestige
in terms of the historical profession.
And he, Bill gave his all to the department.
He did his share, taught his fair share of classes.
He advised students, and we had individual student advising,
probably not too many.
Students who matriculated in his class, undergraduates,
I would say probably 98 percent of them
never knew who they were taking the class went.
And a striking example of this,
I was attending a Western history meeting in Sacramento,
and I was in an elevator,
and a fellow saw my identification card
for the conference, and asked me,
he said, will you map them?
William's still teaching.
And I said, yes.
He said, you know, I had a class with him as an undergraduate,
and I never knew who he was.
So that was kind of an eye-opener for me,
well, it was something I never forgot,
because, you know, wow.
So he would take the bus over in the morning teaching
and take it back.
Yeah, and I think it was seven o'clock return bus,
and he would be home.
Well, by the time I was here,
he was living in Walport,
and so he would leave his car in Newport,
or Wendy would drive, pick him up,
and something like that.
I don't know how that worked out.
So he didn't keep it apart the night?
No, he didn't.
And when he did stay over,
he stayed over Tuesday in Wednesday night,
because he had other commitments,
and he did that pretty regularly.
He stayed at the townhouse.
And it's still a townhouse, I guess, isn't it?
On South Forth,
and it's Tommy's bar and grill,
and then it was just the townhouse bar.
So we talked about the townhouse hotel
or the other house.
No, Creval's hotel,
and I can't remember where we migrated for a while,
and then the townhouse,
we would get together there
for drinks afterwards sometimes.
Can't remember.
There is now, but.
I'm worried about 35 minutes.
Yeah.
Yeah, I'm watching I've got
about 18, 15 minutes or so.
How do you characterize his work style?
Well, I have to back up
because by the time we were talking about
writing drafts of papers and so forth,
and he would use long yellow pads.
He called it full-skap,
and I don't know if that's probably,
you know, a really 20th century term,
and I used the eight half by 11 pads
now they're lined and so forth,
and he used the longer ones,
14 inch, I suspect,
and he would write drafts of material
on that in long hand,
and then he would transfer that,
he would type it on a first rough draft
after doing some editing.
So by the time he was doing that,
it was more or less a third draft
that he was typing by the time he did that,
I know that was part of his routine.
And beyond that, you know,
after he had, if he was writing,
let's say, empires a way of life
or something,
the process of revision,
you know, once he had a manuscript
completed, you know,
I tend to go back through,
well, chapters individually,
and then the whole manuscript.
But that's, of course,
I'm using computers
and Bill never graduated
to use the use of computers,
but he was a fast typist too.
And Prone, pretty error-free, I think.
I mean, if you look at his typescripts there,
pretty good.
So those three days in the coast were generally
developed three days right in that?
I would say yes,
and some of it,
late night,
you know, he tended to work at night,
and that was a habit he developed,
you know, probably when he taught at the Uvoa
and certainly when he was in Madison.
Yeah, that was part of the certain
circumstances that he was having to raise kids.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
He had a house full of children,
you know, two of Carrins,
and then he and Carrin had three children at their home.
And then he, at some point,
it seems to have initially sort of presented
having to do that,
but maybe he came up with that.
Yeah, I don't know.
I think he worked.
You know, I mean,
he was so incredibly productive then.
In addition to turning out
42 PhDs in 11 years.
You imagine that.
Yeah.
Now some of them were still finishing up,
obviously, when he was here.
And I don't know when he told me at one point,
you know, he had placed his last candidate in a job.
And that could have been the mid-70s
and it might have been Peggy Morley or Henry Berger.
I can't remember whom.
You talked a bit about tragedy and concert
as being hugely influential books.
There's sort of a sense that his scholarship kind of declined
a little bit in terms of quality during the OSU.
Did you comment on that?
Well, he said he would never write another book.
And actually my wife and I called him on it
when he published Empires a Way of Life.
And actually America confronts a revolutionary world.
I think he even made that comment before that book.
But he didn't call those books.
He called them extended essays.
So, there was a difference.
And well, then you could call tragedy of American diplomacy,
you know, an extended essay.
Whether, you know, like his first book American Russian relations
or roots in the modern American empire
which were detailed.
Annotated, documented books.
Maybe he called those books, I don't know.
But I would say I was never enamored
by America confronts a revolutionary world.
But Empires a Way of Life is an incredible piece of writing.
And I was telling my friend Sunday,
a historian who was visiting our home,
that Empires a Way of Life.
I don't know how many different languages it's been translated into.
You probably know.
Japanese, Chinese, Italian, German, French.
Add infinitum.
And it's a testimony to the influence of his career,
the body of his work.
And I think as a capsule,
and my reading of Paul Beall kind of reminded me of this,
is how important that book is.
After reading Paul's biography,
I want to go back and read Empires.
That's part of this sort of drawing,
documentation of the idea of community.
And it seemed like that was one of the world-of-fine things
with the intelligence.
Yeah, a lot of people have asked me about that.
And think, you know, because I was Bill's good friend for so many years
that I knew more than, you know,
the snippets that he published here and there about community.
But community and democracy were the small D.
And pretty much everything it's in is writing.
You know, there's nothing hidden anywhere else.
It's kind of an exploration, an exploration of ideas.
I think that he was interested in.
That's what it's what it's all about.
Oh, I think it all has its roots in Atlantic Iowa,
which I stopped in there on a Sunday morning
when I was traveling from east to west.
I think I was back east and I was coming west and had breakfast.
And, you know, it's like a lot of other small Iowa towns
you drive in and you find a diner and, you know,
you're going in a Sunday morning, everyone is there for breakfast.
And I don't remember much about it.
Did he ever reflect on Atlantic around you?
Oh, yes.
Yeah.
And his grandparents.
And it's funny.
He makes, Paul makes more of Mildred.
I think then, Mod, his grandmother.
But, Mod and what's his name?
His grandfather, Tossi, Appleman.
Porter.
Porter, Inkler, Appleman.
They were a real presence in his life.
And, you know, Paul makes, I think,
a more of a psychological play on, you know,
the boy who grew up without a father or something.
And, Porter was a pretty pronounced presence in his life.
And, you know, my association with Bill,
I mean, his grandparents were very important.
And he was very proud of his mother, of course.
I have one other thing I want to say about his upbringing in Atlantic
and he makes mention of 1927.
So, Bill would have been six years old, maybe seven years old,
when Charles Lindbergh flew over Atlantic,
and supposedly yet, his father's.
This may be an apocryl story.
And, Bill remembers seeing the plane in the dipping of the wing
on his fourth.
I've always wondered about that.
My bill was a good storyteller, very good storyteller.
So, I wonder if this is something fashionable that, you know,
he remembers from his childhood and so forth.
And, I tend to have those same, it's probably romantic notions,
myself, about my own childhood.
I think we have a scrapbook actually,
is that right?
Well, then, it's not an apocryl story.
I'm interested to know more about his teaching style.
It was eclectic,
psychratic.
He wanted to engage students in dialogue.
And, I would say it probably worked greatly for sophisticated,
older students, and not sophisticated, but with inquiring minds.
And, I know because I tried it myself.
And, it worked one term, then I tried it with a larger class.
And, I had to give it up,
and went back to lecturing.
And, I would have a lecture format, a framework of discussion in mind.
But, I don't know Bill, you know, he was a master at that.
And, I think that he would lecture from a general outline.
He would just have three pieces of paper with notes in his beautiful penmanship.
And, but they were profound.
When I was away at a conference one time, he met with a night class that I taught.
And, he left me with, it was a colonial history class.
And, it was very early fall term.
And, he left me with a copy of the notes.
And, they're in my papers in your collection.
And, they were, I mean, it was unbelievable.
The world view of what the coming of Europeans to the American continent did.
And, I used to do it in more immediate ways.
Bill's, however, was framed into how you impose on a people new languages,
new frames of reference, new world views, and so forth.
And, I'd have to go back and look at it.
But, I even put that in one of my books, incited his, it's very profound.
So, you came to us to a university about a graduate program,
do you have a sense of frustration that arose out of any of that?
No, no.
Despite what Paul Bill said, I think.
One of the reasons for coming here was to get away from training graduate students,
because he had enough of training graduate students.
And, he wanted to settle in a place where he didn't have to shovel snow in the winter.
And, he wanted to be close to the ocean.
People have asked me about this.
You know, at conferences, when they first learned that I taught at Oregon State in Bill Williams,
I was like, why does he want to come there?
And, I would repeat these three reasons.
And, I had never heard, never heard him say anything other than that.
He told that to interviewers.
He would tell it to Carla and me, when he'd had a couple of bourbons,
and he'd never said anything else.
How about the quality of the student scale, anger, or institution?
Well, I think there was some sense of frustration with that, obviously.
But, he would be very proud of some of the papers his students did.
Here, I know that from time to time.
My impression is that he was a fairly demanding person expected a lot of his students.
Yeah, I'm not sure that he was all that rigorous of a grader.
I can't, you know, I was less interested in those kinds of things.
And, you mentioned that they would do a lot of advice.
Well, it's hard to say.
He did have, you know, we all shared advising.
And, usually, they were students from our own classes.
And, so we would have advisees assigned that way.
I had huge classes.
I know, in the 70s, I was teaching Indian history.
And, I was, in fact, in retrospect, overburdened with students.
I had to use different kinds of roosters to go through grading exams and so forth.
Yeah, I'm interested in my as time to move on.
What sort of role would he assume within the department?
He's never at the chair of the department.
He mentioned that some of this initially was hired.
Right.
Do that resistance disappear?
Do you become kind of a mentor to some of the junior faculty?
Well, I know some of the resentment early on when I was hired.
So, I had a lot of jealousy accusations that Williams was trying to develop a department full of radical young people and so forth.
And, part of it was focused on me and part of it was focused on a young French historian that the department hired to teach African history and French history.
And, this fellow was very bright.
He was very flawed and he never got tenure.
I think by the time this fellow was denied tenure and that was, let's say, by 76 or so, he was gone.
That had fallen by the wayside.
But that was very prevalent at first.
One of the best pieces I thought of that appeared in Northwest newspapers.
And, I don't know the exact date.
It was a piece that Foster Church published in the Sunday Oregonian and had to be about 1983, 84, something like that.
I don't know what the exact was, but I know I clipped a copy of that.
I don't know whether, I'm sure you have it, but it's, and the best part of that I think is the photograph of Bill on the back deck of his home looking south along the coast.
It's a great photograph. It's on the back of Paul's book too.
So, I'm just continuing on. Is there anything more to talk about in terms of the role that he was in within the department of overtime?
No, except the overweaning jealousy thing that I've mentioned just before we break, took the break, was something that bothered me.
And part of it I think had to do with those of us who were really interested in building a department in which people published, taught, and engaged in the professional meetings, gave papers, and so forth.
And those who didn't, and I think that some of that went away by the time of Bill's retirement, 1985, but there were still sharp divisions in the department.
And between what kind of was the quasi progressive Williams faction and those opposed, and it was pretty pronounced, and it lasted until I served one year as department chair.
And I did nothing brilliant, but there were four people in the department who came to me, and I was an interim appointment.
At different times, during the first, right after I was named, Acting Chair, and expressed, you know, real concern about the direction of the department.
And what I told them was that, you know, I was a Democrat with a lowercase D, and that I had no intention of making end runs around people, or pushing any special direction in the department, any ideological agendas.
And by that time, however, the department was changing a lot. There was a cadre of people who had published books, you had to have a book to get tenure and so forth.
And by the time I was through with my year, three of those four people came to me and told me what a good job I was doing, and I wasn't doing anything brilliant, except, you know, we were a different department than, and those kinds of factions went away.
But that was part of, you know, the hangover from Bill's presence here. You know, he was president of the Organization of American Historians for Health, you know, in 1981.
How much does his presence within the university, is he regarding to be something for a star or celebrity?
Oh, yes. I mean, people knew who he was, and presidents knew who he was. He actually got on well with John Byrne, and you should interview John.
Yeah. You know, because Bill assumed, with good reason, that he could speak to John Byrne as an equal, and there weren't many faculty, I don't think, who presumed that they would speak to the president of the university as an equal.
And Bill did.
Bill also played a great role, and you'd have to look into the records of the Center for the Humanities, and getting the Center a major endowment.
And it became part of the university, not the foundation, what's the development, OSU foundation.
They had four major objectives in a push, and one was the Center for the Humanities, and Bill was a major player in that.
And obviously, because of his prestige, his stature and the profession, and he lent his voice to that, and I'm sure that the Center, and I know Peter Copeck, was always very thankful to Bill for that.
Was that, was the Center something that the, Peter, that is sort of a commitment, and brought in to play over?
No, it was Peter's idea. So Williams was enlisted.
Williams was enlisted. Yeah, Bill was not a player. It began as the Humanities Development Office, over in Moreland Hall, and it kind of morphed beyond there, and then when it became a full-blown Center for the Humanities,
that's when Bill was brought in as a good friend of Peter's, along with a few other people, and he was a major force in how that worked out.
We talked about the social setting, the pool table, if larger kinds of gatherings and professional gatherings perhaps received this sort of person who enjoyed hanging in the room, or did he?
No, no.
So you talked a little bit more about how you sort of operated in that situation?
Well, Department of meetings?
No, it might get a professional gathering of sorts.
No, I, he was, I'm people like to talk to him, and I've only been around him at professional meetings when he was with his former graduate students, who were, they were friends.
I mean, they were former graduate students. There was Lloyd Gardner and Walter LaFabre, Ed Craypole and others. They were just dear friends.
He liked them, they liked him, and when they came here to give talks, Bill would introduce Lloyd, or Walt LaFabre, as someone he knew when he first started teaching at the University of Wisconsin,
and he said, you know, it's like your students are smarter than you are, or something, you know, he paid them great compliments.
And I, I just remember my first social occasion, Carlo was with me, when Bill, the organization American Historians was meeting in San Francisco, and we were at the Hyatt Regency down on the waterfront.
And it was late in the afternoon, cocktail hour, and kind of a rotating bar at the top, you sat and you'd see the San Francisco, or the Bay Area, skyline all around.
And, and Carlo and I were there with Walter LaFabre, Lloyd Gardner. I don't think Ed Craypole was there.
I don't remember Jerry McCauley being there, but a couple of other people from the organization American Historians.
And, you know, it was a fun gathering, and Lloyd Gardner was probably the most garrulous of the group, and because Lloyd had, you always had a glint in his eye about some devilish story, and he was a better storyteller in some ways than Bill.
You know, and Bill was just part of the crowd.
Yes, he was. It was recognition, long deferred. As Paul Biel says, Eugene Genevase had been president three years prior to Bill, and, you know, it's funny.
People who have controversial or quasi-radical positions, you know, become presidents of major organizations long after the fact.
One of, I just learned in my own field of Western American history, Donald Worcester is the forthcoming president of the Western History Association, and he's retiring.
And, Don, in a lot of our views, should have been president, you know, in the early 1980s, when he was publishing, you know, good books. He's published good books ever since then.
But he's been a person who's been a bit edgy, like, maybe not as much as Williams, but he's finally going to be president.
And he knew Bill spent time in this house.
And this was not a biographic story, so you had an adventure that you were trying to do.
Yes, he did. And he worked very hard in his year as president, and started, I think, something that girdle learner
who finished, who followed Bill as president, gave him a lot of credit for his initiatives, although they didn't bear fruit, you know, especially with the national endowment for humanities.
He got nowhere. He appealed to several historians who wrote, made thousands of dollars writing textbooks.
He had ten or fifteen of them in mind, and he wanted each one of them to donate a thousand dollars to create this.
And he put five grand in himself to do this, and to no avail.
A lot of the lines is sort of a bit further to honoris that we mentioned earlier at the college.
Also, I would only see one on our adoptee.
Yeah.
I'm Paul makes mention of that.
My answer is so what?
No, no. When he did get the honorary doctorate at Columbia College or something in Chicago, his address had to do with Duke Wellington.
I remember that. I remember reading the talk. He would give Carl and I copies of his talks.
Oh, yes. Love jazz. Yeah. Miles Davis.
Pretty close. Dizzy Gillespie. Who's the one I just mentioned?
No. Duke Wellington. Yeah. Yeah. They were kind of classic jazz.
And I know when we would go to the coast, he invariably have Miles Davis on his stereo.
What were some of the other hobbies that you had to take for a jazz?
He fished. The ocean. I went fishing with him once. We didn't catch anything. We went down in the rocks and yajas.
And I had to stop in a store when I was coming through Wallport to get some bait.
And then I drove up to Bill's place and then we drove south to Yajas.
He liked to fish. We have some of his photography in our house.
And his photography goes back to evidently his childhood.
And we have a... I don't think you have a copy of it, but here I doubt.
Of a photograph that he took when he was a student in anapolis.
And it is striking. I mean, it's so damn creative.
He climbed up on a trancem over one of the major public buildings at the Naval Academy.
And on a Sunday in the sunlight, it's shining through the door.
And people who walk through when they're approaching, they cast shadows.
And there was a woman evidently approaching the door.
And he captured her shadow from a pie over the trancem.
And we have it framed in our house.
And it's a... what do you call it?
Maybe a marble in laid floor, something black and white.
And it's a black and white photograph.
And I imagine it may be black and white in real life.
And then he would take close-ups of items along the coast,
like a rusty hinge somewhere real close to the water,
or gnarly wood that had been weathered and so forth.
And we have several of those. Those were wedding gifts.
And he had photographic exhibits too.
I know Paul mentioned when the new bridge was being built in Walport across the LC.
That's the only photographic exhibit that I know he did.
He may have done others.
But that was one of his applications.
And Paul mentions that he went back to building model airplanes again.
Later, after he retired.
Do you have any of those here?
No, the photographs or the model airplane.
What happened to them?
Ward. His son Ward may have them.
He'd be a good person to interview.
There's several references in the biography.
And no, that's well known.
And I don't think Wendy liked that in the biography.
She didn't like the references to womanizing.
And I know this.
She was visiting us, staying with us actually,
when we lived in Fulhamon.
And my only response to Wendy was that I had been with Bill in thick and thin
when he was drunk, sober, or he never was really drunk.
Or points in between.
And he never ever said anything negative about Wendy.
I had to tell her that.
And I remember, I had tears in my eyes.
I said, Wendy, you have to know this.
And he also could recover dramatically.
And I know that on the eve of his introduction of,
I can't remember the guy who the president-elect introduces the president.
It's a very prominent historian.
And I can't think of his name right at the moment.
In 1981, when we were at the Hyatt Regency,
Carla and I sat in a lounge with Bill that afternoon.
And Bill had, he might have had a drink or two before.
And then he had another one with us.
And boy, he was, like I said, he had Bill.
You know, you have to introduce so and so at eight o'clock for his presidential address.
And he said, OK.
So he goes to his room and he naps.
And we saw him at the dinner, I think.
And it was like, you know, he never had a drink.
I'm really interested in this newspaper column.
Oh, they were great.
Yeah, I loved them.
I saved a lot of them, but I'm sure I missed several.
I used to clip them and put them in a file.
It seems like such an unusual,
thanks for a story to you on such a regular basis.
Yeah.
With respect to you sharing these papers,
are you unusual for these papers?
Yes.
It started with the Statesman Journal,
because he knew one of the executives in the Statesman Journal,
and I can't remember whom, and they liked Ed Bassett.
And they liked each other.
And so that's how it started.
And he got so, and he used to tell me about this,
the number, the word limits.
You know, and how you take an idea and develop,
you know, an essay and you get it down to,
I don't know what is 700 words,
or something like this, whatever the column is.
And, you know, he became very good at it.
And then, I don't know, it was a changing command at the Statesman.
I think he started with the Statesman,
then the Statesman Journal, they merged the two papers did.
And then he migrated to the Oregonian.
And he did that, the Oregonian for a while.
And I think that probably happened in part through David Sarasant,
who was in his early period with the Oregonian.
And then they killed a piece that he wrote.
And they paid him, you know, the kill fee, never again.
That was it.
You know?
Well, it's a real testament.
I mean, he took that as an affront.
Yeah.
So, the column, I think, is a real testament to that idea that he has.
Mm-hmm.
And they're very eclectic.
Yeah.
I talked about a lot of this.
I guess I'm interested in going more about trying to spend with Wendy
at sort of recollections of the wall for it.
Our collective visits to wall for it.
We always had a lot of fun.
And invariably, we would go out to dinner.
Occasionally with friends.
We would go down there.
They'd have friends over.
And the people I remember best were a couple named Barbara and Rob Davidson.
And they were a lot of fun.
Rob was quite a bit older than Barbara.
And he passed on eventually.
And I've seen Barbara just a couple of years ago.
And she's since remarried.
And she was a very good friend of Wendy's.
But Bill liked both of them.
And he liked Barbara, I know immensely.
And they were fun people.
Occasionally they would have people from the OSU community over just a handful.
One of them was a fellow who retired in engineering David Bella.
Yeah.
Now, you might want to interview him.
David's kind of a kind of class in his own right.
You'll talk to your ear off.
That's where we met Dave.
Dave was a really young professor.
Bill thought I know a lot of him.
He liked people with good ideas and so forth.
And he prided himself on that.
Dave was over there one time.
I can't remember anyone from the department.
A fellow named Jim Cole, who was here, is a visiting professor.
Jim was a good friend of Bill's.
But Jim was kind of crazy.
By me Bill would say that.
Jim would admit that himself.
And he was undisciplined.
Bill Meekam.
He's the fellow who didn't get tenure who came from Wisconsin.
It was actually a Harvey Goldberg student and a radical guy.
And Bill had all kinds of problems.
It was booze and couldn't primarily booze.
I think he couldn't finish his dissertation.
But he couldn't get anything published.
And that was his own failing.
And I was good friends with Bill Meekam too.
So together is it really better conversation?
Yeah, or just snack food and drinks and talking about music and just for a couple of hours.
Bill and Wendy did.
We had a bridge.
Carl and I never played bridge.
So we were probably from people from the valley.
We were probably over there more often than anyone else.
And on special occasions, Wendy's birthday.
We'd go to New York Hots for dinner.
One time we went over, I think, during the Christmas New Year's holiday.
Carl and I stayed.
Our kids were getting a little bit older then.
So we left them in a motel and went into YAHOT's for dinner with Bill and Wendy.
And then we would call them every hour to make sure the kids were okay.
By then, they were at seven, eight years older.
Talk a little bit more about Wendy.
Well, she was her own person.
And very, very bright.
And very hardworking.
She loved to garden.
Bill built her a little greenhouse.
Plastic.
She had two pots and so forth.
She also played the piano.
And she worked in a gift shop up in Newport that's still operating.
And I can't remember the name.
If my wife were here, she would remember.
And she was a very hardworking woman.
Very bright, very political.
And I think that's where their friendship, certainly,
materialized because of Bill's politics.
And Wendy, a Brit who came to Corvallas via British Columbia,
was kind of keen on somebody who had politics that she appreciated.
So his fellowship was something that they would discuss?
I'm sure.
And she read voraciously.
I don't think she ever edited anything at Bill Road.
When he made public talks, he might just have her read it just to try it out on her.
There was something that he'd gone astray on or something.
Carl and Wendy were very good friends.
And we remain good friends to this day.
So we talked about his love to see you a little bit.
I don't know if there's anything more to share.
There I'm interested to in the maritime history class that he developed.
Yeah.
The two were one.
Just to give you a quick answer.
The maritime history class actually originated, I think, in part
through the Center for Humanities.
I know there were various of us.
I wrote a course that I taught on community through the Center for Humanities.
Bill did the maritime course, and there were some others.
And I think I can't remember the details, but we got some stipend or something
for doing that wasn't much.
And that was kind of an application for Bill, you know,
touring off and part of his affection for this sea and maritime history and so forth
to do something like that.
And you got interested, of course, in the Chinese early Navy and the famous Southern
who was 11th or 12th century, famous Chinese who I saw his name in Paul's book the other day.
I can't remember his last name.
I had gone out on the high seas and came back and scuttled the Navy.
And Bill used that, you know, as a metaphor for no empire, which I love.
And he wrote a paper having to do with something to that effect.
And he was going to read it at the Pacific Coast Branch Meeting of the American Historical Association
in Honolulu in 1996.
And I was there presenting a paper on another panel and Bill something happened to him
and he couldn't make the trip.
Not in 1996, 86.
And it could have been another meeting of the PCV.
It was about that time, late.
It was 86 or 87, 88, maybe somewhere else.
But anyway, he couldn't make the trip and I read his paper.
And I had a lot of fun doing it because there were a couple of people on the panel
they commented was a person whose area of expertise was Chinese history.
And there were bills venturing in this paper talking about Chinese commander and so forth.
And I had to add a bit of humor to it and I told them why Bill couldn't be there.
And I said, I refused to defend this paper because I know nothing about the subject or something like that.
Anyway, but it was received very well, including the commentary.
And somebody else made very nice compliments to the paper because no one else in American history
was thinking in these venues unless they were specialists in Chinese history or anything.
And Bill had the guts to venture out.
It's interesting to me that he taught this class at a community college.
Yeah, he taught it here too.
And then he taught it at the Co-security College for a while.
I don't know how successful that was.
Well, of course, it's helped the client, if you'd like.
I don't know, to what extent did it reflect on that of any thoughts or memories you might have to share?
You know, I know he, the week before he died, the cancer massacized.
And he kind of had a stroke because he came walking down the hallway and he was gesturing to Wendy.
He couldn't speak or anything.
And within five days, I think he was dead.
And Carla and I went over and saw him in the hospital.
David Cleaver, who was a famous physician in Corvallis, was a good friend of Bill's.
And David was there when we were there.
And he explained, you know, he said he's semi-comatose or something.
His eyes could open a little bit, but he wasn't corresponding or anything.
And he was under morphine then.
And he was on the way out.
Wendy, of course, had worked in hospitals, a lot of her life.
And she knew that the end was near.
I felt bad.
I told Wendy, you know, because I was busy with my own work.
And I enjoyed going over to talk to Bill.
And I would just drive over and have coffee with him or something like that.
And I felt badly because I hadn't been over for a month.
And she put my soul to rest.
And she said, that's neither here nor there.
What was the local reaction?
Well, this is something I learned.
And I learned this from Ed Craypole.
I always thought that Bill and Wendy went to the Episcopal Church because of Wendy's influence.
And I was totally wrong.
That was Bill's choice to go to the Episcopal Church.
And he was, I don't know whether he helped with, you know, the sacraments or something.
I don't know.
But Wendy went just to accompany him.
Wendy was out.
And is a radical quaker.
Her sister, her husband, Alan, her Wendy's brother, Alan.
They're in the truest, radical quaker tradition in England.
And it was Bill, Ed Craypole told me this.
So I said, you mean Bill is high church, not Wendy?
And he said, yes.
So Ed Craypole is the guy you should talk to about that.
That was striking to me.
Yeah.
And I think, and I was reading between the lines and what Paul said that his kind of sense for order and maybe hierarchy
or something later in his life attracted him to the Episcopal Church.
And I don't know what his church bringing wasn't Episcopalian.
I don't think in Atlantic.
But I do remember that.
Well, is there anything else that we should touch on?
No, I do want to have one final thing.
And Bill's passing is something akin to my mother's passing.
And she was killed in an automobile accident at the age of 60.
And right after she had retired as a factory worker.
And I had obviously an immediate period of grieving.
But when I went back east for going through a wake, my father was Catholic.
My mother wasn't, but my father wasn't a practicing Catholic.
But he just thought, you know, there's people who die need wake.
So we had this damn wake.
And I met my mother's friends from the factory, who came in by the droves.
And I never shed a tear.
And it was nice to meet all these people.
And Bill's passing is somewhat like my mother's because my mother has a living presence in my life.
Bill has a living presence in my life.
I mean, I remember him as the conversations happened yesterday.
And that's healthy.
Thank you, Jerry.
You're welcome.